we have to have something to kill time  have you heard anything good luck no not  yet is what I'm doing browsing through  disease you heard anything fun  no not yeah probably got a late start or  something you know get a little worried  about you know I try to be strong in  front of girls you know keep a brave  face you can do all the planning in the  world but you never know what you're  looking at until you get in there and  this is an extreme case of excess skin  we're gonna have to spend a little extra  time liposuction on your arms but we run  the risk of the real complications I  mean as soon as we lasted a lot longer  than the other surgery maybe that the  recovery some be longer recovering from  the surgery is hard enough and I don't  know how she's gonna recover when I tell  her she's not invited the strippers  wedding  [Music]